[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEVEN BUTSCHI: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for coming, especially
9:00 AM after a concert.
How many of you made it out
last night to The Chainsmokers?
Oh, wow, a lot of you.
And you're here.
So well done to you.
My name is Stephen Butschi.
I lead our higher
education team at Google.
And this session is on
disaster recovery and storage.
And we've got some
great universities here
that will be speaking.
But I'm sure you
probably all remember
the news from about a year
ago with Hurricane Harvey,
and that we happened to
have a school district that
reached out to us and said,
we learned a hard lesson.
Your disaster recovery
site should not
be located just 30 minutes
from your main data center,
because that may
also be affected.
And they reached out and said,
we're having some problems,
if you could really help us out.
And the good news is, with
Google Cloud Platform and G
Suite, we were able
to step in and help
them recover from this.
But I think what we want
to talk about, hopefully,
today is helping you avoid what
happened with Hurricane Harvey
and making sure that you're
thinking through your strategy.
So as you hear from
these three universities,
you'll hear a little bit
of the first two buckets.
So I wanted to call
this out because there
are different types of storage,
the first being G Suite.
This we offer for free
to many institutions
that are educational,
in fact, all of them.
They're not for profit.
And so that is
really around file
storage as you think
about backup and recovery,
so things like
essays and manuals
and presentations,
collaborative docs.
So you'll hear from Steve
from University of Minnesota
about how they are using Google
Drive for backup and storage
of those types of materials.
The second bucket is around
Google Cloud Platform
in our storage classes.
So that is more object storage.
So think about disaster
recovery, large sets
of genomics data, et cetera.
We also have other
types of storage,
such as block storage
and structured data
through Cloud SQL.
And I put the link
there because there
are so many to list that I won't
be able to go through them all.
But if you want to check
that on the website,
there is more details there.
So when we think particularly
around disaster recovery
and storage for Google, I
think there's four key terms
that we are trying
to design for;
trust, secure,
smart, and simple.
So if we go into
that, for example,
with Google Cloud Platform,
one of the things you have
to do in order to trust
someone is make sure,
if you're going to put all
of your files or your object
storage into Google, is you
trust this will actually
be available when you need it.
And so this is some
data from Gartner
looking at the
downtime of storage
from the different
cloud providers.
And hopefully we're
recognizing that we
will be there when you need us.
In addition, there are
a few other features
that I think differentiate when
we're looking at cloud storage
options.
One is a single consistent
API, so you don't
have to manage multiple APIs.
And that API actually works
with other cloud providers
as well, which
makes it really easy
to move data, edge
caching, given our network,
making sure that the data can be
easily brought to you quickly,
consistency and things
around security,
like default encryption,
that's automatically
encrypt data at
rest and in transit,
as well as object
lifecycle management.
So as you look at, for
example, our different buckets
of storage, going from
hot and multi-regional
all the way on the left to cold,
which is really just archive,
we can really easily help
you move your storage
through that process
automatically
through lifecycle management.
The benefit of that to
you is that, if you're not
touching something, you
can move it down in a class
and it will save you some money.
So as we go through
this process--
and I'm not going
to read through all
these different buckets--
but just remember
that we have many different
scenarios and different options
to match what you need
for disaster recovery.
So as we go from
there, I'm going
to introduce three
of our speakers.
We'll have Arun
from Stanford, who
will be talking about how
they're using Google Cloud
Platform for their
disaster recovery, Steve
from University of Minnesota,
who will be talking about how
they're using G Suite for
a lot of their file backup,
and Joshua from Georgia State,
also talking about how they're
using Google Cloud Platform.
And then at the end,
we'll take questions.
So if you have any questions,
feel free to jot them down.
We have a microphone, and I will
be moderating that discussion.
So from there, I'm
going to bring up Arun
to tell us about what
they're doing at Stanford.
There you are.
[APPLAUSE]
ARUN AGGARWAL: My name is
Arun Aggarwal, Lead Cloud
Engineer at the Stanford
Graduate School of Business.
Let's dig right in.
Let's talk about
disaster recovery.
As an introduction, I'd like
you to look at this picture.
It's a beautiful picture
of San Francisco.
It's got the cityscape in the
background, the fog rolling in,
and the very famous Golden
Gate Bridge peeking out.
STEVEN BUTSCHI: I'm
going to give you this.
There you go.
ARUN AGGARAWAL: Is that on?
OK.
And the very famous Golden
Gate Bridge peeking out.
San Francisco is truly
a beautiful city.
And I hope in the
last few days you've
been able to take a few
minutes to look around, enjoy
the sights and scenes.
But San Francisco is
known for one other thing,
and that's earthquakes.
We who live here know about
these natural disasters
very well.
This entire area is situated
on six major fault lines
and a slew of smaller ones.
In fact, geologists predict
that, in the next 25 years,
there is at least a 70% chance
of a significant quake hitting
on one of these faults.
It could happen tomorrow.
It could happen next year.
You don't know.
But what we do know is the
damage that earthquakes can do.
Back in 1989, we
had a 6.9 earthquake
that hit San Francisco,
the whole area.
It was dubbed the
World Series earthquake
because it happened just moments
before game three of the World
Series in 1989 that was
between the San Francisco
Giants and the Oakland
A's, just across the Bay.
And you can see
what damage it did--
a big gaping hole
in the Bay Bridge,
a downed building in one
San Francisco neighborhood.
Both of these were
just moments away
from where we're
sitting right now.
So let's bring this back around.
If you, as an IT
professional, are
responsible for your critical
data for your organization
and you happen to live in
an earthquake-prone area,
or any place that
has disasters, you
want to make sure that
that data is safe.
This morning, I'd
like to take you
through our journey of creating
a disaster recovery plan.
In doing so, I'll talk
about three major topics;
why we chose the Cloud,
why we chose Google,
and how we achieved disaster
recovery with zero downtime.
The Graduate School of
Business at Stanford
has over 200 terabytes of
critical research data.
This data is sitting
on our NAS, on premise,
on storage disk from a
major storage vendor.
Our faculty researchers use
this data to create and publish
major papers on
topics from anywhere
from international
economics to human behavior.
This research is
world-renowned, and it's
critical to attracting top
talent to the university,
both faculty and students.
Amazingly, as of
just two years ago,
this data was not
even backed up.
Clearly, we needed a
disaster recovery plan.
And we needed one
implemented very quickly.
As we talked about it, many
requirements came to mind.
We wanted to make sure
that our disaster recovery
plan was geodiverse.
As I've just been
talking about, we
didn't want an earthquake
to hit a data center
and take out our NAS and
RDR solution all at once.
Our solution had to
be highly available.
Our solution had to be scalable.
As our data footprint grew,
we wanted the solution
to grow with it without
any major rearchitecture.
And we needed quick
recovery times
in the event of a disaster.
As we did our basic
research, it was clear,
and we were appointed very
quickly to using the cloud.
It was the most efficient,
the most cost effective way
of achieving these
various goals.
Add to that the fact that
the university had recently
printed its Cloud
Vision Statement, in it,
it stated that the
university wanted
to move the majority of its IT
infrastructure out to the cloud
by 2019.
That's just next year.
But that confirmed the
direction that we were going.
I'll let you read Stanford's
Cloud Vision Statement, which
is up here on the screen.
And it will, again, point out
the key words; cost-efficiency,
scalability, and accessibility.
Cost, of course, is a big
factor on any major initiative,
especially when you're dealing
with university budgets.
In our case, when we started
thinking about disaster
recovery, we thought, hey, why
not just bring in another NAS,
bring it on premise, copy all
the bits from our production
NAS to the second
NAS, and thereby we
would have our solution?
We talked to our storage vendor,
and they sent us a quote.
The quote came in at $137,000--
not chump change for us.
Further, that didn't include
the installation costs,
nor did it include the
system administration costs
that we would need to
bear over the lifetime
of this new solution.
Google Cloud Storage,
by comparison,
had minimal upfront costs.
And it billed monthly,
depending, of course,
on the size of your
data footprint.
We estimated that, in the
first year, that would come out
to around $60,000 for us.
You can see the big
price difference.
Beyond cost, there
were many other reasons
as to why we chose Google.
Our university had already a
preexisting business agreement
with Google.
And in that agreement, we
could store high-risk data out
into GCS, and even PHI data.
That was important to us.
Second, we had a fantastic team
assigned to us from Google.
Once they learned
about our project,
they worked hard to find the
right solution for our DR.
They communicated
with us continuously.
And as a matter of fact, we met
at this very same conference
a year ago.
I was able to sit down with
them, talk about our needs,
talk about our requirements.
They took lots of notes.
They went back.
They figured out some
possible solutions.
And they came back quickly.
Once we talked about
it, we discovered
that there was a
particular Google
partner that would potentially
serve our purpose very well.
I'd like to go into in
a little bit of detail
about that particular partner.
That was a company
called Komprise.
Komprise is a company
and a software
that allows you to
analyze, move, and manage
your data across all your
disk volumes and, in fact,
across object stores
out in the cloud.
Together with GCS,
the Komprise software
provided for as a complete
DR solution, and one
that we have in place today.
The company itself was
wonderful to work with.
They developed a collaborative
relationship with us.
They were eager to
hear our feedback.
We were eager to give
them our feedback.
And in fact, much of that was
introduced into future versions
of their software.
That's all fine and good.
But what really
sold us on Komprise
was the capabilities
of their software.
From this picture,
I hope you can
see that we were
able to replicate all
200 terabytes of our
research data out to GCS.
Moreover-- and
this is important--
the files came over while
preserving all file attributes.
More specifically, it preserved
all security file attributes.
And even more
specifically, it preserved
NFSv4 security file attributes.
We came to learn that NFSv4
is not highly supported,
but it was critical
to our solution.
Once all of our
data was out at GCS,
the Komprise
software then allowed
us to actually mount that
Google GCS bucket back
to our on-prem compute hardware.
I hope you can see then that
if our NAS ever went out,
we could simply
mount the GCS bucket,
and we would be up and
running with our data
with zero downtime.
As they say, that's exactly
what the doctor ordered.
In conclusion then,
I want to state again
how important it was for us
to achieve disaster recovery.
We did it with GCS
and with Komprise.
And together, they formed a
solid solution that, again,
is in place for us today.
Looking ahead, now
that all of our data
is safely out into the
cloud, we could imagine, hey,
maybe instead of having
our on-premise data,
maybe our primary storer
should be out in the cloud.
And if we did that, we could
then take the next step
and think about, hey, maybe
we should put our compute out
in the cloud.
In essence, we would have Google
do all of the infrastructure
heavy lifting for us,
and we could concentrate
on what value-add
we're there for, namely
the data, data analysis, data
integration, and that sort
of thing.
Putting all of that compute out
into the cloud also minimizes
our on-prem footprint,
which is a very good thing--
no servers, no
administration, no headaches.
And when you live here in
earthquake-prone country,
as I was talking about,
you don't want to mess
around with losing your
data and your compute.
Thanks very much.
I'm going to hand
it over to Steven.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE NGUYEN: Thank you, Arun.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Steve Nguyen,
and I'm with the University
of Minnesota.
I'm the service owner for
collaboration and web content
services.
The University of Minnesota is
comprised of five main campuses
across the state of
Minnesota, the Twin Cities
being the largest.
We have about 100,000 students
and approximately 35,000
faculty and staff.
My role here is to ensure
that the service is delivered
through operations,
process improvement,
and through
strategic [INAUDIBLE]
in the collaboration
web content space.
What I want to talk about next
is the University of Minnesota
and how we have
200 million files
and 2.3 petabytes in the cloud.
We're ready for storms,
tornadoes, and even
the occasional squirrel.
And I'll explain that one later.
While we don't have
earthquakes like Arun did,
we have other things that
cause us to think about DR.
And so I want to walk you
through how we've done it here
at the University and
how you can do the same.
The University has been an early
adopter of Google since 2009.
But we didn't all jump right in.
As I look back to those
days in the late 2000s,
we were contemplating
about moving to Google
as a collaboration platform.
We had pockets of users
using Google and wanting
leadership and others to
move into this direction.
But the rest of the campus
didn't have an appetite for it.
Faculty were concerned
about storage,
how they access their
files, where they find it.
Administration were concerned
about security, performance,
and uptime.
But all in all, the
questions really
boiled down to two things.
One, can we trust Google?
And two, will
Google be reliable?
So through a series of town
halls with stakeholders
and with leadership,
we concluded
that the benefits in
the cloud just far
outweighed those concerns.
For example, we used
to use Word docs.
You know how you create
them, you send them off,
someone would download
them, make changes,
send them right back?
Well, since we've
moved to Google Docs,
the experience for our users
has been just tremendous.
They now have in any time,
anywhere, and any device
real-time collaboration.
We also wanted to strive
after a high-availability
infrastructure.
So we asked ourselves,
as an institution,
how do we minimize the
downtime that students, staff,
and faculty have in
using these products?
And so we were after high
availability to the five nines.
And I think we have pretty
much achieved that with Google.
But the largest benefit,
however, is in the savings.
And that's what I want
to talk about next.
The savings we achieved
from going to Google
were in time and money.
We used to spend a lot of
time managing servers--
patching them, monitoring
them, troubleshooting them.
You know how that works.
And usually we would
get a vendor patch,
and we applied them, and
we think that they've
tested it thoroughly.
They didn't.
We applied them.
Of course, disruption
and disaster, right?
Well, since moving
our files to Google,
we don't have to worry
about that anymore.
Google does a better
job of it than we can.
So why not let them manage it?
So our sysadmin is now really
focusing on other priorities
where their expertise
is needed in that area.
The other benefit
that we mentioned
were the savings
in terms of money.
We asked Gartner to come in
and do an independent analysis
of what the savings would
be if the University moved
to an all-cloud collaboration
platform versus building
something on-prem.
They determined that
the university would
save approximately $15 million.
For those in higher
education, you
know that's not a small number.
And it's always a decreasing
budget every year,
right, so we're asked
to do more with less.
And so my question to
you is, what could you
do with $15 million
in that savings?
Well, what we did was we
went to administration
and went to faculty,
and we said to them,
here's something you
don't hear every day.
Here's $15 million for you.
What do you want to do with it?
They came back, and
they said we want
this, a collaborative teaching
and learning classroom.
This is where the University
invested the savings.
This building here houses 10 of
the high-tech active learning
classrooms that
we have on campus.
For those who aren't familiar
with what high active learning
classrooms are,
they are classroom
designed to offer a
flexible environment that
encourages group work, class
participation, and increased
participation.
Students here are working
on projects together.
They're collaborating, sharing
their results within each other
and the classroom
through technologies
implemented in that building.
This facility is also
a big draw on campus,
not only for teaching
and learning,
but for also other events that
need a collaborative learning
space.
Steven can recall
that he was here
at this same place in March
for our Google Day event,
using the facilities and
the equipment in this room.
But these students,
however, have
an ever-increasing expectation
of availability and reliability
on the Enterprise
applications that we
have in our data center.
And so I want to take a look
at two examples of where
the impact of those data
centers caused a DR situation.
The picture on your left
shows you a large body
of Minnesota water.
And the picture on
your right shows
you one of the
University's data center.
Imagine all this water
flooding into that data center.
When that happened, obviously
our files and servers
were unavailable.
And our users were very
upset, and they didn't
want this to happen again.
So we thought about how
we would mitigate this.
And so we said, we
need to have a cloud
file storage solution that would
allow the users to continue
to access their
files and store them
without having to
worry about a flood,
because moving the data
center was not an option.
And so what we wanted
to do was we looked
and moved to the files that
we had to Google Drive.
And so our most
recent flood wasn't
as severe as the first one.
But when it happened, we
were already in the cloud
and we were unaffected by
that from a user standpoint.
My next DR example occurred
when we had an important upgrade
that we went live with.
We had a complex,
year-long project
to upgrade a key
business application.
And the upgrade was
complete, and we
were ready for the launch.
On the day of the launch,
one of the transformers
powering our data center
blew up and caught fire.
And obviously this
delayed our launch.
Anybody care to guess what
caused that transformer
to catch fire?
AUDIENCE: Squirrel.
STEVE NGUYEN: Yeah.
Good.
You guys were paying attention.
That's right.
So hard to believe,
but a squirrel somehow
found its way into
the transformer,
built its nest or whatever,
and caused the fire
to take down our data center.
Yeah.
This caused IT to
have a huge black eye.
So all credibility
and trust with IT
went out the window that day.
It took us a long time to
rebuild that relationship
and earn their trust again
in our partnership with them.
You can't really
plan for anything
that's unexpected, right?
And here are two
examples of that.
I can share more of just
some of these crazy stories
that you just can't plan for.
But by leveraging
Google, what we did was
we took all of our files
that everybody was using
and put them in the
cloud to prepare
and plan for these unplanned
events that happened.
Like our users,
this squirrel here
was just looking for a safe
place to store its nuts, right?
So isn't that what
we're here, too,
to learn about how we can
securely store our files?
Now that we talked a
little bit about DR,
I want to switch gears and
just talk about Team Drives.
Imagine a scenario
with me for a second.
You have a staff person
who's been with your place
for seven years, creating
content and so on.
They're ready to move
on now, and now it's
time for them to go.
How does an organization
effectively offboard
that person while
retaining these documents
and make sure that they
don't leave with that person?
How does your organization
do that right now?
Well, prior to Team Drives,
whenever a staff person left,
they had this daunting
task ahead of them
which they didn't want to do.
And that is that
their teams needed
them to change ownership of
all the working documents
that they had and assign
that to a new person.
And this was a process
that was very haphazard.
It was painful for the business.
The staff person
who was departing
really didn't want to do this.
I've got another week left.
I'm not going to sit here and
spend hours trying to change
ownership of documents.
And so we would usually have to
contact that person after they
left and ask them to
reassign these documents
to another person.
Well, Team Drives
improves this for us.
And it allows the team
to own the documents
versus an individual.
And so Team Drives helps us have
a better offboarding experience
and allows us to improve that
process in a more effective way
so that the documents stay
with the organization.
So in conclusion,
you can see how
we've done at the University--
focused on security,
performance, availability,
real-time collaboration,
and with team environments.
The savings we gained
from moving to Google
allowed us to
reinvest those funds
into areas where
the student learning
experience has made
the University one
of the top places to attend.
And going forward, we
want to be able to look
at moving to an all-cloud
file storage solution
where applicable and continue
the momentum of moving
these files we
have to the cloud.
We want to continue to develop
Team Drives in an environment
for colleges and business units
to put their files in and have
a better offboarding experience.
As you can see, we
have 200 million files,
and we're just getting started.
Thank you, and I'll
hand it over to Josh.
[APPLAUSE]
JOSHUA HUMPHREY: Good
morning, everyone.
My name is Josh Humphrey
from Georgia State University
in Atlanta, Georgia.
And this morning I'm
going to share with you
how Georgia State has
moved into the cloud
and how that move has greatly
improved our overall disaster
recovery planning.
Our main priority was, how
could we better protect
the University's
data without breaking
the bank in the process?
So many of you may
remember a small storm
that happened last
year, Hurricane
Irma, and the destruction
that it caused.
Atlanta, which normally does not
receive storms of this caliber,
was in the projected path
as it was entering the US.
So since this was
our first major storm
that we were going
to face, luckily we
had already started
moving our backup data
into Google Nearline storage.
We knew this storm was going
to put GCP to the test,
and we felt very
confident that we
were going to be able
access our data in case
the worst were to happen.
So knowing this information,
we were able to not worry about
how secure and how
safe our files were.
The whole team could then
focus on more pressing issues
as we prepared for
the storm to hit.
Luckily, at the last
moment, the storm
weakened and actually
changed course.
So we did not have
any major outages.
But it did help us prepare
for any future ones that
may come down the road.
So our initial move to
the cloud was very small.
We took very small baby steps.
We had an initiative
several years back
that was wanting us to
move some of our workloads
into the cloud.
So we decided to not focus on
major applications and systems.
Instead, we decided
to keep it simple,
and we targeted our 100-plus
terabytes of our backup data.
The reason we
targeted this was we
were the ownership
of the backup data.
So we didn't have to deal
with other application teams,
and we didn't have to open
up a lot of extra security
rules and stuff, working
with those teams.
We could do it all in-house.
So knowing that our backup
application actually
supported multiple
connections to clouds,
we chose Google Nearline, and
we decided to start a pilot.
So within a couple
of days of deciding
we were going to do this pilot,
we created our GCP accounts.
We then created our storage
buckets within Nearline.
And we connected our
backup application
into the storage buckets.
The next step was we created
a new storage policy,
and we dumped a couple
of our dev systems
into that storage
policy to have that data
start shipping off to Nearline.
So for about two months,
we let that system
run while we learned how
to manage this data--
what was the process of
adding new systems, what
was the process of restoring,
so on and so forth.
So two of the main questions
that we were asking ourselves
while we were doing this
two-month pilot was,
was cloud going to work for
us for our disaster recovery
planning for our backup data?
And was Google going to be the
best option for hosting this?
So after the two
months' timeframe,
we found out how easy it was to
add more systems into Nearline.
We found out how easy
it was to restore
these systems, both at a file
level and a full server level.
And so at about eight
months, we were good.
We decided to go all in and
pushed all of our backup data
into Google Nearline.
So now that we
were all in, it was
time to toss our
security blanket aside.
And doing this saved us
a lot of time and money.
And let me explain.
So prior to getting rid
of our security blanket,
we were using tapes
as our DR plan.
So every day, our backup data
would be copied to tapes.
We had a dedicated
team in our data center
who would go in,
rotate the tapes.
We had a third party company
come in, pick up the tapes,
send them off to a
secure remote site.
If we ever needed
to restore anything,
we would contact that
company, hoping that we
requested the correct tapes.
They would bring them back in.
We would load them
into our tape library.
And all that to just
start doing a restore.
So we decided it was now time.
We felt confident in
Google and the ability
to restore this data
in case we needed it.
So we decommissioned
that tape library
and became 100% dependent
on GCP in case of disaster
or any other type of emergency.
So now that we no longer
had the tape library,
we no longer had the other
hardware costs associated,
and the other third
party support,
we saw a yearly
savings of around 44%.
And we've been using GCP
for almost three years now,
and we've seen this about
the same amount every year.
So as Steve said,
in education, that
is a huge amount when you're
dealing with budgets that
aren't constant year to year.
And because this is such
a significant number,
we often use this
whenever people ask us,
why did you move to the cloud?
And we just bring this up
and say, this is our savings.
So this is one of the
big reasons we moved--
usability and the savings.
Aside from the cost
savings, we also
were able to reallocate about
10 of our data center workers
into other areas of
the IT department
where their skill sets
could be better used.
So instead of working
on swapping out
the tapes and everything,
those individuals
could then go work
either at our help desk.
Some of them went into
our server admin team,
and some of them went into
our networking admin team.
So it was a better
use of their time,
better use of the
University's time and money
having them moved out
and into the other areas
of the University.
So now that we were all in
with GCP, with using Nearline,
we were now able to reap
some of the benefits of using
cloud services, three of
those being location, access,
and growth.
So being in Georgia, we
have a 30-mile requirement
for our DR site.
Google's data centers are far
beyond Georgia's boundaries,
so we immediately gain
that check mark of,
is your data outside of a
certain mileage radius in case
there was a disaster recovery?
We also have the ability to a
simple configuration change,
and we can then have
that data replicated
to one of many other data
centers within the country.
We also have near instant
access to our data.
Like I mentioned
before, with tapes,
we had to contact the
tape library company,
have them ship the
tapes back to us
before we could even
start that restore.
Now, through our
backup application,
a couple of clicks
and we started
streaming our backups
back to our data center
almost near instantly.
And we also have the
ability to grow and expand
our retention rates
for our backups
without the cost
of extra hardware,
without the cost of the extra
cooling in our data centers,
and the electricity
that comes with that.
So now within our
backup application,
one configuration change
and we've expanded
our overall retention rate.
We can add days, weeks, months,
even make it indefinite,
and it only costs us the monthly
storage bill from Google.
So since we are
utilizing Nearline,
we recognize that we're
still only scratching
the surface of the services
that Google and using
cloud technologies provides us.
So one of the main things that
we're looking for in the future
is, how can we get
to the point where
we can utilize a lot
more of the services
that Google provides, and
hopefully with the ability
to one day just flip a switch
and have all of our mission
critical systems come
online near instantly
within GCP so we can continue
running our data center
as seamlessly as
possible, and then
see what other integrations
we might be able to utilize
that Google offers.
So in conclusion, my advice to
any of y'all in the audience
who is looking to either start
your journey into using cloud
technologies, or if you
want expand on your current
environment, pretty much is to
just keep it simple and start
with the small things.
Since we had an initiative
and we decided to not focus
on large applications-- we just
took small chunks of things
that we knew we could get
those easy wins with--
that's kind of the biggest
advice I can give to anybody,
is we all probably
have a big picture
of what we would like to
get to in the long run.
But find those little
pieces of that picture,
try to get successful in those.
And then as you work
on those little pieces,
the success rate
keeps going up and up,
and then eventually you've
covered the whole picture
that you were looking to do.
And thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]